[Music]
victor's in san jose hi victor welcome
to the ramsay show
dave good afternoon how are you better
than i deserve what's up
dave i've uh i wish i i got on here
playing a few years ago i'm a new
listener and um the plan that i've had
for myself is very muddy and cloudy
and so
like your plan and i hope i'm getting
i'm gonna get some insight here uh hey
talking directly to your phone brother
hey you're muffled like crazy you need
to speak directly right
there there you go
sorry there you go um so
is that better yeah sure right
so we we make quite a bit of money over
three hundred thousand dollars a year
and with uh tax deductions and all sorts
of benefits that we pay for out of that
and saving for retirement uh we take
home roughly two hundred thousand
and uh
so then i i started doing a whole lot of
things and maybe i took on too much so
um
the fundamentals here i have about
eighty thousand dollars in savings
i have two hundred thousand dollars in a
401k
i have thirty thousand dollars in a raw
forty two thousand dollars in an index
fund that's since you guys right
um and
um i've got a house mortgage for 365
thousand which i don't listen to let me
stop you a second i apologize but we
can't do your whole financial plan
what's your question
oh um
so my main question was i i took on two
rentals that i have um
i have a mortgage on
and the idea was that i would keep these
for 15 years and they would pay for my
kids college
cool fund good
and
i've got a mortgage on them they cash
flow positive to pay that mortgage but
i'm not sure if that's a great idea yet
and i've got these index fund uh forty
two thousand dollars sitting there that
i'm also going to use as a liquid
fund for kids college or
whatever is needed 15 years down the
line okay i'm going to back you all the
way up and pan out to
clarify you said you've got this
murkiness because there's too many
things going into me directions so let's
just streamline it right down the baby
steps so make sure you have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
setting liquid
in a simple savings account don't touch
that for anything that's just for
emergencies make sure you're debt-free
but your house i think you are based on
what you're saying you're making really
good money
then at baby step four you need to be
putting 15 percent of your household
income into retirement
you're putting some of your money into
retirement you talked about the
difference in your 300 down to 200 so i
don't know exactly what that number is
but go back and recalculate and make
sure you are putting 15 percent of your
income into retirement baby step five is
kids college six is pay off your home as
quickly as you can
and so you've got some rentals that
you're thinking you might use for the
kids college you might do some other
things so i'm taking the 42 out of the
index fund i'm taking some of the money
out of the 80 000 sitting in savings i'm
gonna set some aside for that three to
six months of expenses i'm gonna throw
the rest of it at your personal mortgage
when your mortgage is gone then we'll
reach over and start paying off those
rentals
and so let's get the mortgage knocked
out and then start paying off the
rentals as fast as you can and just
direct your cash flow at those things
instead of instead of dispersing it
across so many different things because
what you're realizing is is that by
spreading out the focus by not having
any focus the money loses its power
when you focus it narrow it down and
rifle it rather than shotgun it it'll go
a lot further a lot faster much like a
rifle versus a shotgun does and so that
that's what you've got to do here and
that's the beauty and the clarity of
these baby steps and walking them that
way hang on man i will send you a copy
of the new book baby steps millionaires
it'll talk about what i'm talking about
here and exactly how to do it to turn
what you're doing into millionaire
status but the clarity is what you're
missing you're all over the place with
it and you're right you you
self-diagnosed that really well yeah so
and man you'll sleep better yeah you'll
just sleep better you live in that
chaotic life everything's everywhere
you'll just have a more peaceful life
now when there's a circus going on in
your brain it's hard to sleep i mean
it's just it's that's normal